[Music]
researchers have recorded the genome in
4d tracking the location of DNA strands
in three dimensions over time our
chromosomes don't always look like neat
little X's a lot of the time our genetic
material more closely resembles a pile
of spaghetti even in the spaghetti state
Gene's move further and closer with
purpose forming loops of DNA many loops
of DNA in the sprawling genome are bound
by cohesin molecules the cohesin acts as
an extruder pulling two areas of DNA
together and extruding out the loop from
the material in between by removing and
then adding this protein researchers
made specific DNA loops disappear and
then reappear but cohesin really only
affects looping that brings genes on the
same chromosome into contact a second
still undefined mechanism seems to bring
genes from different chromosomes
together the shifting landscape of loops
helps cells quickly change which genes
are actively understanding this dance
could help researchers better understand
and treat genetic disease
[Music]